avec nous pour en parler ce soir mode
laberge qui est professeure adjointe au
département d'opération et un système de
décision de l'université laval madame
laberge bonsoir alors parlons d'abord de
ce contest concert tests à barcelone
tout le monde a été testée masques et
5000 personnes
est ce à dire qu'il est possible de
permettre des rassemblements sous des
conditions strictes comme celles là mais
après c'est une expérience très
intéressante qui nous permet de penser
non pas est-ce qu'on peut ou pas faire
quelque chose mais plutôt dans le
comment est-ce qu'on peut recommencer à
faire des activités qu'on appréciait par
arda pandémie et quelles sont les
mesures qu'on peut mettre en place pour
minimiser les risques pour reprendre ses
activités donc dans ce cas si
effectivement comme vous l'avez
mentionné le dépistage avec un test
antigénique avant le concert le port
d'un masque ffp2 daumas qui limite en
petit limiter la transmission d'un
aérosol au moins 92 % donc comme un haut
degré de l'unité vers la religion mais
si il y avait eu des tests au niveau de
la narration dans la salle donc des
conditions vraiment minimiser les
risques pouvaient être présents pour
permettre ce constat n'est cette
expérience j'ai fait c'est une
excellente nouvelle dans les résultats
qu'on observe et les tests que les gens
ont subi on pourrait faire ça chez nous
est ce que ce serait coutu d'utiliser ce
type de test mais la question aussi
qu'on peut se poser c'est scacchi de
payer pour ces tests là donc si on est
prêt à payer pour un billet concert ou
une autre activité
est-ce que ce que c'est aux
organisateurs de payer pour ce test ou
est-ce que c'est aux participants qui
veut assister à ce spectacle est ce que
parce que les gens seraient prêts à
payer un vin ou un train supplémentaire
pour alors billets pour que ça vienne
avec avec ce test il y un masque donc
pour pouvoir participer à l'activité de
façon sécuritaire
aujourd'hui les centers for disease
control and prevention aux etats-unis le
sidi sidi une personne complètement
vaccinés donc qui a eu le johnson
johnson une dose ou les autres vaccins à
deux doses au complet peut se promener
sans masque et n'est pas obligé de faire
une quarantaine au retour d'un voyage
est ce qu on comprend que le vaccin
devient donc la liberté totale
j'irais pas jusqu'a dire la liberté
totale mais en grande partie oui
des études récentes suggèrent de quatre
ans que pour les vaccins heures duo
intègre et moderna le risque d'attraper
le lac aux 19 sont réduits de 90 %
donc ce n'est pas au complet pour les
personnes qui auraient reçu leur dose on
va être entièrement vacciner et de 80%
pour tous et qu'elle ait reçu une seule
dose pour astrazeneca et johnson &
johnson s'est un peu moins élevé mais ça
reste donc réduit grandement le vis des
transmissions et donc évidemment on est
encore dans une réduction du risque et
par conséquent ça peut permettre
justement un peu trop à la normale à la
liberté au québec changement tant
aujourd'hui du premier ministre les
jours meilleurs semble semble approcher
commun devront s'y prendre pour le
déconfinement telle quelle serait la
bonne approche
mais je pense qu'il faut combiner les
stratégies à la fois donc évidemment de
continuer la vaccination
puis on a parlé de passeports vaccinale
qui pourrait faire partie de la
stratégie aussi de déconfinement mais
l'exemple de ce concert aussi nous donne
une piste par rapport à l'utilisation
des tests antigénique pour être
implantées dans les activités avant que
les parties y assister à des concerts
des choses comme ça ça permettrait
d'accélérer finalement le retour à ses
activités de rube réel aux dépens de
l'économie et pour l'instant ce serait
quand même à risque de propagation s'ils
ont la peau de telles mesures en place
et quand monsieur legault parle de
séquences de réouverture est ce que vous
comprenez qu'on s'en va vers des
possibles rassemblements qui pourraient
même ressembler à des concerts cet été
j'ai pas de boule de cristal pour savoir
est ce qu'il va se passer mais j'imagine
aussi que ça va dépendre de la capeb des
données biologiques on aura au québec
à ce moment là donc là la proportion de
personnes qui seront vaccinées au 6 mai
mais de penser aux stratégies aussi
qu'on peut mettre en place donc c'est à
dire l'utilisation des tests antigénique
ça pourrait faire partie de la solution
pour ouvrir plus rapidement certains et
pour permettre certaines activités comme
comme des concerts cet été très
intéressant merci de cette analyse
madame laberge a fait plaisir au pouvoir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit